un cerveau que l'on dit détruits edit
compatibles avec la vie de bonheur
l'amour
je m'appelle sur une belle image des 51
ans je suis marié et père de cinq
enfants
j'avais 43 ans 24 août 2014 ce 24 août
2014 mon épouse amélie fait une fausse
route d'alimentation c'est à dire
qu'elle à val de travers un morceau de
viande qui lui obstrue la trachée elle
s'étouffe
son coeur manque d'oxygène son cerveau
manque d'oxygène elle perd connaissance
et ce ne sont pas les modestes gestes de
secourisme que je vais pouvoir tenter à
secondes et des enfants qui sont
présents qui pourront inverser le
processus
les pompiers arrivent très vite le
service médical d'urgence à suivre et
arrive enfin à désobstruer la trachée au
décours de la désobstruction il semble
se passer quelque chose mais amélie est
mis sous coma artificiel
sous ventilation artificielle et sous
alimentation artificielle
en quelques minutes
la vie a basculé et la violence du choc
et comme un violent glissements de
terrain qui met à nu toutes les couches
géologiques qui vous constitue qui se
sont accumulés en vous depuis le premier
jour sont vous puissiez encore savoir
son client quand savoir lesquels sont
simplement mises à nu celles qui
seraient blessés ou celle qui serait
peut-être déjà amputé
explore ton monde
les premières couches géologiques on va
voir apparaître réapparaître c'est la
famille et des amis extraordinaire qui
vont pouvoir venir en couverture et en
fondation faire en sorte que l'ensemble
ne s'effondre pas
trente six heures après son accident une
tentative de réveil est fait pour amélie
c'est à dire qu'on essaye de la sortir
du coma artificiel
je suis au près d'elle c'était la nuit
et par deux fois alors qu'elle est
totalement immobile de la voix levé
comme ça deux fois les mains vers le
ciel
les médecins diront par la suite que ce
n'était qu'une activité réflexes et puis
surtout je vois l'infirmier et l'inter
nhs qui s'inquiètent et qui s'agite
parce qu'il voit apparaître soudainement
des micros tremblements sur son visage
et son corps qui vont aller en
s'amplifiant
à partir de là il va me falloir
apprendre très très vite ce que c'est
qu'un états de mal épileptique
un état de mal épileptique
c'est
une crise d'épilepsie qui ne s'arrête
pas on mesure activité électrique du
cerveau par un électroencéphalogramme
qui en donnent une image et vous avez
ici
l'électroencéphalogramme d'une personne
dite normale
et voici
l'électroencéphalogramme d'amélie à ce
moment là
qu est ce qu on peut y lire que si
lisible que c'est très intense que c'est
totalement anarchique qui lie à des
à-coups épileptiques
grosso modo le cerveau est comme une
machine dont le bios serait attaqué qui
n'arrivent pas à rebooter qui n'arrive
pas à se relancer l bugs attendent de
fonctionner dans tous les sens mais rien
ne fonctionne le plus grave ce n'est pas
l'intensité du phénomène c'est le fait
qu'il dure et qu'il ne s'arrête pas tant
qu'on peut penser que cela crée et même
à graver les lésions
le médecin que je vois le lendemain et
qu'ils m'attrapent pas le bras me dit
monsieur ce n'est pas grave monsieur
c'est très grave
d effectivement c'est très grave
le 29 août 5 jours après l'accident
je visite amélie le matin je sais qu'ils
ont tenté depuis plusieurs jours
quelques traitements dont les résultats
ne sont pas très encourageants et là
je vois qu'ils ont arrêté l'alimentation
et l'hydratation et ça c'est un deuxième
choc peut-être plus fort que le premier
parce que je sens et je pressens là que
le regard des médecins est le mien sur
la malade commencent à diverger
l'après-midi l'ue reçoivent
lorient rendez vous et il m'a dit que
les derniers traitements été effectué et
qu'il n'y a plus d'espoir il ne sert à
rien d'attendre
amélie va mourir
et de toute façon même si elle ne
mourrai pas soit quoi ils ne croient
même pas de toute façon elle ne se
réveillera jamais
à ce moment
je suis un homme à terre mais qui aura
fort de cette prescience peut-être juste
la force de pouvoir leur dire docteur ça
va trop vite trop de précipitation je ne
suis pas prêt parce que je sais moi qui
leur ai dit que ça allait trop vite
alors ils vont reprendre à l'hydratation
mais pas les une alimentation et dans
les jours qui suivent pour faire face au
phénomène par face à la situation et
bien je n'ai que ce que je suis et ce
que je sais
et moi qui suis un modeste ingénieur
agronome je sais moi que la carte n'est
pas le territoire je sais docteur que
l'examen n'est pas la malade vous ne
pouvez pas réduire amélie à son électro
encéphalogrammes oui c'est grave c'est
très grave mais ne la réduisent pas à
son électro encéphalogrammes et puis
docteur je sais moi ce que c'est que les
statistiques
vos statistiques sont biaisés
si vous leur avez tous arrêtés
l'alimentation et l'hydratation
c'est normal docteur qu'aucun ne soit
réveillé oui vos statistiques ne disent
que c'est grave est que c'est très grave
mais elle ne me donne aucune certitude
et puis
le fils que je suis
c'est ce que c'est qu'une prédiction
auto réalisatrice car le fils que je
suis a vécu quatre mois plus tôt la mort
de son père
papa avait fait une sorte de fausse
route également mais qui lui ne l'a pas
étouffer lui la donne et une infection
pulmonaire et le médecin qui le voit le
vendredi nous dit toute façon il ne
passera pas le week end on ne faut pas
le nourrir parce que sinon il va à
nouveau site ouf les
trois semaines plus tard
papa était toujours là et comme l'arrêt
de la nutrition provoque des oedèmes eh
bien on arrête l'alimentent on arrête
d'hydratation
cinq semaines après son accident papa
était toujours là
de quoi est mort papa je ne sais pas
mais ce que je sais c'est ce qu'est une
prédiction auto réalisatrice
alors je goûte mois la gentillesse il a
la délicatesse des infirmières et deux
aides soignantes qui sont auprès
d'amélie
j'apprécie la disponibilité des médecins
et c'est là sans doute leur première
qualité ces médecins qui m'écoutent ou
plutôt qui ne m'écoute pas vraiment
monsieur
vous allez finir par comprendre
monsieur c'est une fin de vie
techniquement ce serait de l'acharnement
thérapeutique
ce serait de l'obstination déraisonnable
monsieur je crois que vous avez perdu
votre femme
a une amie qui visitait amélie
écoutez ça sert à rien de parler là il
n'y a plus personne il n'y a plus
personne
jusqu'au siège de service qui me dira
monsieur je connais vos convictions je
connais les siennes je connais les
vôtres mais je dois vous le dit
son projet de vie c'est de mourir
je vous laisse le recevoir
mois son projet dit c'est mourir ce sera
deux jours et deux nuits
d'intenses très intense insomnies et qui
vont se conclure par un cri un véritable
cri des profondeurs
amélie
je t'aime
et puis
montrent une colère intérieure sourde
est forte docteur je vous interdit de
dire ça docteur son projet de vie c'est
nourrir ce n'est pas médical c'est autre
chose mais ce n'est pas médical
et puis son projet de vie docteur il lui
appartient d'abord à elle c'est une
affaire entre elle et moi il n'a fait
entre elle et vous entre vous et moi
entre vous et nous mais certainement pas
à vous tout seul
deux jours pour comprendre
15 jours pour se faire entendre
et comme je suis peut-être le seul qui
observe encore amélie rompu peut-être
aussi de l'observation et bien je
m'aperçois qu'amélie redonne le rythme
au ventilateur
ça ne change rien les tad mal est
toujours là et même il s'aggrave mais
comme l'alimentation est arrêté
je sais que l'heure tourne il est temps
de décider et donc je vais leur donner
le feu vert pour l'arrêt de la
ventilation pour débrancher comme on dit
mais je vais juste mettre une condition
docteur j'ai compris
elle va mourir
et si elle ne meurt pas elle ne se
réveillera points
mes docteurs vous allez lui laisser une
chance vous allez lui laisser une chance
de vivre
parce que
cette chance elle ne vous appartient pas
et elle ne m'appartient pas vous allez
faire une explication normal
le 5 septembre
deux jours après son accident
amélie et ex tubes et c'est à dire qu'on
lui enlève le long tube qui va jusqu'au
fond de la trachée
et amélie
respire
elle respire même très bien et de toute
façon en plus du premier coup mais
j'étais prévenu il n'y aurait pas de
deuxième tour
alors il va me falloir encore cinq jours
pour imposer la reprise de
l'alimentation vous comprenez monsieur
c'est encore une fin de vie
et puis
durant tout ce temps
et comme durant les semaines qui suivent
en fait je n'ai eu aucun espoir on ne
m'a pas laissé le temps d'avoir de
l'espoir parce que l'alimentation est
arrêté le temps tourne je suis pressé je
suis pressé de toutes parts je n'ai pas
eu le temps d'avoir l'espoir mais ce que
j'ai reçu je les ai reçus d'amélie est
ce que j'ai reçu c'est l'espérance
et qu'est ce que c'est que l'espérance
si ce n'est à vue humaine
l'émerveillement d'être encore habité
par la vie
le 16 octobre 2014 sept semaines après
son accident
amélie se réveille
elle prononce ses premiers mots de
langage articulé ses premiers mots
comprendra une que comprendra une amie
qui vient la visiter en premier ses
premiers mots je ne sais pas ce qu'ils
veulent dire mais je vous les donne
j'ai faim j'ai soif et j'ai mal au dos
alors de toute cette histoire
eh bien
j'ai fait un livre une pièce de théâtre
puis le plus je l'aimais est une pièce
de théâtre et pourquoi une pièce de
théâtre parce que le théâtre c'est
démodé parole des dialogues et à quoi
servent les mots et les paroles si ce
n'est dans les situations extrêmes a
pesé soupesé le poids et la valeur de la
vie
seize mois d'hospitalisation qui seront
pour amélie à la fois d'une victoire une
semi-victoire
une semi de fête et peut-être même pour
certains une défaite puisque amélie
reste lourdement handicapé et le
handicap a cette particularité d'être
comme une prison qui se resserre dont
les murs se rapproche de vous tente il a
réduit le champ de vos possible des
vôtres mais également celui de vos
proches
dont il est difficile de faire certaines
choses avec amélie ou pour nous mais
aussi pour elle et dans s'occuper d'elle
consomment tellement d'énergie et puis
il ya aussi tous ces murs du deuil du
deuil affranchir du deuil de l'ami de la
vie d'avant pour passer à la vie d'après
parce qu'il n'y a plus de vie d'avant
c'est du mur du deuil qui vont du déni à
la colère en passant par la tristesse
jusqu'à l'acceptation et à la
reconstruction ces murs du deuil qui
viennent et qui reviennent dans les
frustrations sont importantes rien ne
dit qu amélie les aura franchi avant sa
mort ou même avant ma mort mais ce que
nous savons tous deux c'est qu'il ya un
mur infranchissable que nous aurons à
franchir ce mur c'est la mort mais il ne
viendra que lorsqu'il sera l'heure
alors comment vous présentez amélie
amélie voit flou et double sas et
neurologiques elle qui est visée trois
bouquins par semaine elle peut se tenir
debout mais anna paquin équilibre elle
peut avoir des peut bouger tous ses
membres mais ça n'a pas de convention
film tu lui donnes de l'autonomie l'art
est fortement épileptiques elle est
il fidèle à elle même je dirais que la
situation même fait en sorte qu'elle a
un peu amplifié multiplier décuplée
centuplé son mauvais caractère
mais
pourquoi vous décrire une personne
handicapée parce qu'elle ne peut pas
faire plutôt que par ce qu'elle peut
faire
amélie était encore à l'hôpital et je me
souviens très bien qu un soir où je la
visite elle me dit très précisément il
faut que tu prennes la méthode de
lecture léo et léa dans le deuxième
étage hier du placard de la cuisine que
j'avais acheté pour blanche
parce qu'il est le moment où elle est
sensible à la lecture vous savez qu'il
existe un moment où une phase où les
enfants sont particulièrement sensibles
à la lecture blanche avait 6 ans
et deux mois après blanche savez lire
l'instinct maternel est inaliénable
et que dire de cette victoire familiale
victoire de tous ceux et celles qui
accompagnent amélie lorsque le cas de
juillet 2020 au prix d'efforts
importants elle va accompagner pour son
mariage notre fils ce n'est tout le long
de la nef de l'église jusqu'à l'autel il
est des pas qui en valent plus que
d'autres
alors
on pourrait tirer des tas de leçons
notre histoire on pourrait tirer des
leçons sur ce que c'est que
des tas de mal épileptique lorsqu'il est
réfractaire aux traitements sur ce qu'on
en sait ce qu'on en sait pas vraiment ce
que c'est que l'éthique médicale celles
qui tentent de vous arracher un
consentement sauf que c'est que les
cliniques médicales en fin de vie sur ce
que c'est que la fin de vie elle même
est ce que la fin de vie c'est ce sous
statut de citoyenneté ou un médecin ou
un collège de médecins mais ça ne change
rien peut décider seul et au final de
votre destinée est ce que ce n'est pas
le moment où il est le plus essentiel de
prendre le temps nécessaire tout le
temps nécessaire pour construire un
consensus fort et explicite dans
l'incertitude qui mêle à la certitude le
naturel à l'artificiel dans
le déraisonnable y côtoie le raisonnable
et dans le mystère de la vie il ya le
dernier compagnon de la souffrance
jusqu'à la fin
mais ce que je voudrais vous laisser
c'est un simple témoignage
parce qu'un jour peut-être dans votre
vie et certains l'ont peut être déjà
vécu vous aurez à choisir entre le
bonheur et l'amour
choisir entre le bonheur ce bonheur que
nous cherchons tous ce bonheur que je
vous souhaite le plus grand et le plus
fort possible
l'état de bonne heure il est un peu
comme l'état de bonne santé et qu'on me
direz le dr knock c'est un état précaire
qui ne présage rien de bon et le
handicap nous le rappellent tous les
jours
choisir entre le bonheur et l'amour
l'amour qui est en vous
l'amour que vous portez
l'amour qui est vous l'amour qui est la
vie de votre vie et bien si un jour vous
avez à choisir entre le bonheur et
l'amour
explore ton monde
retrouve cette liberté intérieure qui
seul te donnera une paix profonde parce
que la liberté n'a jamais été de faire
ce que je veux encore mois ce qui
m'arrange ni même ce qui t'arrange la
liberté c'est d'abord de savoir ce que
je fais
alors le témoignage que je peux vous
rendre c'est que simplement lorsque
commencer
grave même quand c est lourd même quand
c'est du même pensé très dur même quand
c'est extrêmement dur et même si ça dure
il est un choix qui ne m'a jamais laissé
le moindre regret merci et bonne route à
tous
[Applaudissements]